in their previous episode and that's why
we continue welcome to you get no show
Coco um this is probably the scariest
[ __ ] Japanese game I've ever [ __ ]
play this is not walk normally okay
what's your [ __ ] problem
Jason's alright it's a good exercise
though I got it I got a given that I get
goosebumps from the [ __ ] intro ever
can see it at all what are we doing here
that was a girl here let's just go - yes
okay I got [ __ ] go the train is
coming
that is common woman la-di-da one
she's not going to be there not gonna be
oh yeah yeah oh hey check man [ __ ]
these you know it's bad when I scream in
Swedish like that that was not [ __ ]
good then energy I'm [ __ ] out of this
[ __ ] you know what it was a good good
while it [ __ ] me you don't know what
it's like to stand here on this [ __ ]
platform and have it okay but go my
quick going what's up what's up and I
want to party because I don't sure how
long oh I got a lot of funky one [ __ ]
[ __ ] keep calling me I'm pretty
popular with the ladies as you can tell
oh [ __ ] what is that hooter knowledge
did you turn on the TV brochacho us that
a woman in there that is a woman that
can you see that [ __ ] this is like that
[ __ ] no it is not oh okay we're going in
here hello ladies ha okay all right
that's why I came from I'm an idiot
oh good we're going in here hello do not
kill me please this is not like dying
all right this looks safe
fine let it get back over there and I
can open it up what the hell does to
have a migraine oh that's fine what oh
[ __ ] they're coming up got a run for it
nah we running for posture patch they're
coming ah dang it
they need become p jeab big died down
there
doubtful no get ready okay brownie can't
run it kept running
it's just when I shake the control he
turns around stop counting in a row okay
that's fine that's time that's fine
in down the hall Ginny up here strikes
again down that [ __ ] down that [ __ ]
down a [ __ ] oh oh oh thank heavens
thank heavens oh no no no no I don't
want to go down here what do we get out
of our pot okay that's not a side [ __ ]
coming back
oh [ __ ] four fine odds Green soil of
[ __ ] hi I'm Karen one a fine wife I are
you scared rough ha ha ha ha ha I'm not
scared
why poses only at a 150 that's that I
guess about a shake man Oh [ __ ]
shadows and [ __ ] what are they doing
down here I know my name is terrified
please don't kill me
those hands out of the wall over here
I'm pretty sure I can't go that [ __ ] I'm
fine I'm just gonna have a heart attack
that's fine that's fine
hello tickle each other Oh give me out
oh yeah yeah no hug for you no I'm for
you that [ __ ] you could hug me we don't
have to jump scare me okay that's the
rules remember that for cat ready
this is the [ __ ] Japs go digging why
did you post please cut it
we're running we're running by running
we are running late Oh Oh Tommy I don't
want to play this game coming down here
going down going down here yeah that was
good fun maybe let's just deal with it
I'm
Clym woman where is he I don't know
Thank You Tucker okay we're fine it's
just the girls ghosts can't hurt me
where the hell did it go or ships go
down this is my golden chest
this is my golden chance this is my
golden town I did it I did it I did it I
let it bloom
negative all right we're going in here
for us oh my god I do not really want to
go here but I guess I don't have a
[ __ ] choice
come on I want to just lie down on my
butt there's something down there I
don't like that
nights off okay don't campaign
all right so far [ __ ] run just don't
look back don't look back don't look
back
we're fine we're fine it happens all the
time so all the time she's right behind
me
it doesn't [ __ ] matter just [ __ ] me
though I don't give a [ __ ]
oh we're [ __ ] I give up I give up okay
okay okay okay okay that's enough fun go
up Oh what [ __ ] up Oh juju catch oh
Jesus
oh [ __ ] we're back here on me well that
was fun
[ __ ] what do you want no I will not go
on a date video
I'm Way too handsome you're out of my
league woman alright okay okay that cone
I don't trust your code [ __ ] here cone
this is going over here
hush what do you want
alright I think I did it I did it for us
coming up say you better get this party
started
whoa
ah that does not look what a pity pathos
we unlocked a new one will I play it
[ __ ] no [ __ ] that [ __ ] all right
what do we do breasts yes you first want
to do it I'll do I'll do it for you
easily you look beautiful
oh [ __ ] we're playing uh Stefano bras
and it's gonna be fine she's just peeing
don't don't look
a true gentleman don't look what a woman
pays that's something I learned don't
ask why
okay
yeah help IANA
hello
is that my brows you love me ah hi come
on in here
you ready hope that what the what ah
door in the forest I hate for us this
that's fine
what there are some really nice for us
if you really think about it I never
really thought about it up
[ __ ] you okay boom babble live on my dad
arriving wait go I feel like I've been
here before us what about here boom
bingo game my breast that was it for me
today as much as much my poor heart can
handle I do not want to play this
anymore
hope you enjoyed let me see how long I
record it no one gets upset about me not
recording long enough 40 minutes
that's [ __ ] good enough for me how
good run it up so you like so much
favorite if you really like
yeah